i'm so lucky i do i walk around with a
joyous experience i have two beautiful
children and haitia's sons are sharing
the touching reason for their mother's
final resting place i decided i'm going
to be the best mom
and
dad
oh
the late actress's 20 year old son homer
released a statement with his 13 year
old brother atlas explaining why they
chose to enter their mom's ashes at the
hollywood forever cemetery homer first
thanks the people at the burial site for
their kindness compassion and generosity
of spirit he says quote we are convinced
our mom would love the site we have
chosen for her it's beautiful serene and
she will be among her hollywood peers if
i'm doing
a satire i hope i'm good in that if i'm
doing a romantic comedy i hope i'm good
in that there's this saying let go and
let god
and that's kind of how i live my life
the hollywood forever cemetery is known
for its showbiz history where hundreds
of screen legends were laid to rest
among them judy garland mickey rooney
jane mansfield anton yelchin chris
cornell and many more but most important
for homer and atlas they point out that
the cemetery is actually a venue for
local gatherings quote hollywood forever
is a living place where people attend
movies and concerts and other events she
was our mom but the kindness and the
outpouring of the past few days reminded
us that she also belongs to her fans to
the entertainment community and now to
the ages i would say to anybody you know
go for what you
feel truthfully in your life and you
will be rewarded a million-fold
according to anne's death certificate
her body was cremated on august 18th at
the hollywood forever cemetery e.t has
learned she has not yet been buried and
details on a burial or a memorial
service have not been shared